[Música]
santiago yo no puedo entender como
alguien se levanta de mal humor
esa misma frase la repitió mi vieja
durante todas las mañanas que convivimos
bajo el mismo techo
y de alguna manera me marcó
mi mamá fue muy sabia y sin saberlo
provocó en mí un interés muy particular
porque yo quisiera entender mis
emociones porque yo era muy consciente
del mal humor con el que me levantaba
para que se den una idea no toleraba que
me dirigiera en la palabra
no me gustaba que estuviera la radio
prendida
no me gustaban los ruidos fuertes y
además tenía un reloj despertador muy
moderno
que un día tira la basura porque él solo
son arte su alarma me irritaba
y ni hablemos de llegar a la cocina y
que estuviera la tele prendida
yo insisto en que esas teles de tubo de
los 90
siempre emitieron una vibración
que también me irritaba
para esto un poco más crecido miro para
atrás
tomo conciencia y me doy cuenta que no
era nada sencillo convivir conmigo en
esa época
pero no me ha dado una buena ducha se me
pasaba el mal humor y me convertía en lo
que hoy me atrevo a llamar una persona
emocionalmente estable
pero bueno era una adolescente así que
tan estable no era
pasaron los años y recién fue mucho más
adelante cuando yo logré desarrollar
este interés por las emociones y fue en
la universidad cuando leí un primer
artículo que hablaba sobre el concepto
de la inteligencia emocional
en ese preciso instante
nuevo universo lleno de posibilidades y
completamente nuevo se abría ante mis
ojos
y es que a través de la inteligencia
emocional los hombres y las mujeres
tenemos la capacidad de entender y
controlar nuestras emociones
y yo no estaba controlando nada
y menos si hablamos del enojo
el enojo fue siempre una emoción que
estuvo muy marcada en mí
el enojo me llevaba a golpear paredes
golpear muebles romper objetos revolear
los por el aire
[Música]
el enojo supo llevarme a lugares muy
oscuros
lugares de los que de a poco me quise
escapar
pasó el tiempo y yo seguí leyendo
material sobre inteligencia emocional
pero ella por cuenta propia
y recuerdo que en una oportunidad leí un
libro de un autor norteamericano que
pareció impresionante lo que proponía
y no sólo eso sino que a través de este
libro el lector podía acceder a
completar un cuestionario online de
manera completamente gratuita para
conocer sus niveles de inteligencia
emocional yo quería saber cuál era mi
nivel
pero resulta que para completar ese
cuestionario
uno tenía que ingresar un código que
venía impreso en la portada de papel del
libro
unas hojas que sobran y que tire a la
basura el mismo día que compre el libro
yo les conté que cuando me enojaba
revoleaba objetos por el aire no hace
falta que les diga que hice con el libro
estamos bien
siguió pasando el tiempo y de alguna
manera yo empecé a fanatizar me con esto
de la inteligencia emocional es más
en muchísimas oportunidades lleve
material sobre este tema como excusa
para iniciar una conversación o como un
disparador de ideas y los que padecían
eran los estudiantes de mis clases de
inglés
a mí es todavía que compartirlo
y empezó a llamarme la atención que
estos autores que yo leía y que también
acosaba
y ellos proponían entender a la
inteligencia emocional como esta
habilidad de entender y controlar las
emociones propias
y también entender y controlar las
emociones de los demás
por lo tanto yo en este momento estoy
controlando mis emociones y no saben
cuánto
pero a su vez estoy controlando las
emociones de todos ustedes
era utópico esto el principio era
imposible apenas yo podía con mis
emociones encima esta gente proponía que
yo iba a poder con las emociones de los
demás
si yo no podía con mi enojo
como voy a poder con el de ustedes
y ahí empecé a darme cuenta que la
inteligencia emocional tenía un campo de
explotación bastante limitado
porque si bien se proponía la
inteligencia emocional como la clave del
éxito para el desarrollo personal y
profesional de las personas otra vez
nadie hablaba de esto en la calle
y resulta que esto de la inteligencia
emocional tiene una explicación
biológica
y esque
el órgano que entra en juego es el
cerebro
los cerebros porque resultan que el ser
humano tiene tres cerebros
algo así como la vaca con sus múltiples
estómagos pero en realidad se trata de
tres estadios en la evolución del
cerebro humano
en primer lugar tenemos un cerebro
reptiliano que es el que corresponde al
del hombre de las cavernas a través de
este cerebro nosotros nos alertamos ante
el peligro y buscamos satisfacer
nuestras necesidades básicas
un segundo estadio es el cerebro límbico
aquí es donde nacen las emociones y
desde acá se disparan y desde acá
respondemos cada vez que lo hacemos
emocionalmente
y también tenemos un neocórtex que es el
estadio más evolucionado del cerebro
humano y es a través del cual todos
nosotros podemos razonar
algo que me atrevería a decir que no
venimos haciendo con mucha frecuencia
pero que hay atrás de todo esto cuál es
la materia prima de la inteligencia
emocional y es que son las emociones
pero que es una emoción
para entenderlo de manera sencilla vamos
a decir que una emoción es una respuesta
que sale de mi organismo ante los
estímulos del universo
y se dice que hay al menos media docena
de emociones aceptadas por todas las
culturas como lo son alegría enojo
tristeza desagrado miedo
y seguramente ahora se les viene a la
cabeza una película de animación de hace
algunos pocos años
es que este tema está en todos lados
las emociones realmente están en todos
lados solo que no les prestamos atención
la inteligencia emocional propone poder
llevar nuestras emociones desde el
cerebro límbico hacia el neocórtex poder
llevar las emociones desde un cerebro
emocional hacia un cerebro racional para
qué
a reflexionar sobre el tipo de respuesta
que voy a dar
voy a poner un ejemplo
recién cuando me presentaron
se dijo de mí que soy una persona que le
gusta viajar me encanta viajar y es
cierto necesito siempre tener uno o dos
pasajes emitidos a donde fuera
pero a pesar de que me encanta esta
actividad de viajar no siempre despierta
en mi las mejores respuestas emocionales
el día que compró un pasaje a buen
precio
yo les aseguro que soy el hombre más
feliz sobre la faz de la tierra
el día del viaje llegó al aeropuerto
y me entero que el vuelo se demoró
cuatro horas
a esta altura sería redundante decirles
que me enojo
y en un aeropuerto nunca revolvía nada y
jamás revolear yo en mi pasaporte eso
que quede claro
me voy de viaje a paso bárbaro
vuelvo y cuando vuelvo llega el resumen
de la tarjeta
descrédito
ustedes no se imaginan con el miedo con
el que yo abro ese resumen
y la tristeza que siento cuando ya lo
pagaréis la cuenta me quedo en rojo
las emociones están todo el tiempo todos
los días en cada una de las cosas que
hacemos y estoy seguro que ustedes en
este momento están pensando en qué rol
ocupan las emociones toman las emociones
en sus tareas diarias
quizás ahora ustedes están preguntando
entonces con esto que me están contando
se trata de diferenciar cuáles emociones
son buenas y cuáles son malas
la mala noticia que tengo para darles y
es que no hay emociones buenas no hay
emociones malas las emociones son puntos
la inteligencia emocional propone
trabajar sobre las emociones una vez que
aparecen para que para reflexionar sobre
ellas y pensar en el tipo de respuesta
que yo voy a dar
pero cuando yo pienso en ese tipo de
respuesta tengo que estar muy atento a
un parámetro importantísimo
el tiempo
porque las emociones tienen una duración
aproximada de 90 segundos sí
un minuto y medio es lo que dura una
emoción en nuestro organismo y si
nosotros no nos dan no nos tomamos este
trabajito de pensar en nuestras
emociones dentro de ese parámetro de
tiempo corremos el riesgo de entrar en
un estado emocional
entrar en un estado emocional no solo
nos lleva a emitir una única respuesta
abrupta sino que además genera cambios
anímicos en mi organismo y luego me
cuesta muchísimo más volver a la
normalidad
o sea que entonces no solo tengo que
reflexionar sobre todas y cada una de
las emociones que aparentemente están en
todas las acciones todos los días de la
vida sino que además tengo que hacerlo
en un periodo de tiempo muy corto
qué trabajo
pero lo bueno
es que como les conté el órgano que
entra en juego en esto de la
inteligencia emocional es el cerebro y
la neurociencia nos enseña que el
cerebro puede aprender
cuanto más práctico la inteligencia
emocional cuanto más práctico esto de
momento voy a reflexionar
ok entonces veo si me enojo o no
cuanto más lo practico más fácil es cada
vez que tenga que volver a hacerlo
y volviendo a esto de el tipo de
respuesta que yo voy a dar la
inteligencia emocional busca que todos
nosotros en su práctica podamos aprender
a responder asertivamente
y qué es esto de responder asertivamente
se trata de encontrar un equilibrio
entre aquello que yo quiero decir pero
al mismo tiempo que respeto a las ideas
de los demás
la asertividad
que viene en empatía
y la empatía es esta habilidad que
tenemos las personas de ponernos en los
zapatos de otros
la empatía implica
y solo a través de la empatía y sólo a
través del respeto nuestra sociedad va a
mejorar sus canales de comunicación
los individuos vamos a aprender a
comunicarnos mejor
para qué
para encontrar esa armonía que tan
desesperadamente andamos buscando por el
mundo
esa armonía que nos va a permitir ser
felices con uno mismo
y también con los demás
yo les propongo
que empecemos a poner un poco en
práctica de esto de la inteligencia
emocional
y es que la vida es casi tan cortita
como una emoción
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]